donc il faut que effectivement vous
venez avec vos armes et on vous les
récupère mais si je me fais arrêter sur
la route je vais expliquer on est au
courant hein c'est national c'est le
message est passé les communautés sont
au courant les plus municipales aussi
donc je retourne chez moi j'habite à
Draveil je retourne chez moi je remets
tout dans ma voiture tout dans votre
voiture il y a des balles aussi
[Musique]
pour nous c'est un vrai enjeu de
sécurité publique et de sécurité tout
court c'est d'abord le risque de
l'accident domestique deuxième objectif
c'est le cambriolage et donc le vol de
ces armes on a chaque année 8000 armes
qui sont volés sur le sur le territoire
national et qui peuvent se retrouver
ensuite sur des réseaux criminels et le
troisième objectif c'est évidemment la
lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales on sait tous s'agissant
des féminicides qu'on a un féminicite
sur trois dans lequel on utilise une
arme à feu et la plupart de ces armes
elles sont non déclarées inconnues de
l'administration les gens que vont être
abandonnés
toutes les armes du département